veamos cuánto es 2.211 dividido entre
6.7 bueno lo primero que hago es que ya
que no me gusta dividir entre decimales
voy a multiplicar este 6.7 por 10 lo que
en esencia es mover este punto decimal
un lugar hacia la derecha y bueno si
hice esto con el 6.7 también lo tengo
que hacer con el 2.2 11 así que movamos
este decimal un lugar a la derecha
y ahora puedo reescribir el problema
como 22.11 /
67 y puedo escribir el punto decimal acá
pero tampoco es necesario ya que ahora
tengo un número entero 67 y ahora estoy
lista para hacer una división larga ya
que voy a dividir por un número entero y
bueno aquí todavía tengo números
decimales pero está bien ahorita vamos a
ver cómo trabajar con esto en un momento
vamos a hacer una división larga vamos a
tomar
22.11 o 22 con 11 centésimas y vamos a
dividirlo entre 67 y antes de comenzar a
hacer la división quiero asegurarme de
no perder el lugar de el punto decimal
si mi decimal está aquí tengo que
subirlo acá y cuando hacemos estas
divisiones largas es muy importante
hacerlas con cuidado y con limpieza
poner los números en las columnas que
les corresponde según su lugar de valor
si no hacemos esto se nos va a perder el
lugar de valor y nos va a salir mal toda
la división
bueno 67 cabe en 20 veces no nos cabe
aquí vemos el siguiente número 67 cabe
en 22 pues 0 veces 67 es más grande que
22 no cabe 67 cuántas veces cabe en 221
este número es muy cercano a 70 setenta
por tres serían 210 así que podría ser
que esto que para unas tres veces vamos
a intentarlo ponemos el tres aquí tres
por siete es igual a 21 llevo 23 por 6
es igual a 18 más 2 es igual a 20 así
que tenemos 201 la diferencia entre 221
y 201 es de 20 tenemos 10 aquí tenemos
un 2 acá y un 0 acá es 20 así que tres
es correcto si 3 por 67 hubiera sido
mayor que 221 pues ya no nos serviría y
si 3 por 67 hubiera sido
pequeño comparado con 221 que aquí como
residuo tuviéramos un número mayor de 67
también no nos serviría este 3 quiere
decir que aquí cabrían más 67 pero este
número es correcto la multiplicación es
menor pero el residuo es menor que 67
vamos a continuar ahora podemos bajar el
1 y cuántas veces cada vez 67 en 201
bueno pues ya lo vimos justamente en el
paso anterior 67 cabe en 200 13 veces 3
por 7 es 21 llevamos el 2 pero bueno
aquí hay que tener cuidado de no
confundir este 2 que llevamos con el que
llevábamos la vez anterior aunque es el
mismo problema y en el anterior teníamos
un 2 debemos tener cuidado de no
confundirlos así que 3 por 6 618 más 220
restamos y ya terminamos esto es cero
no tenemos residuo y no hay nada más del
lado derecho de este número así que
22.11 entre 67 es y ponemos un cero aquí
por no dejar
es 0.33 esto es igual a 0.3 3 o esto es
igual a 0.33 y terminamos